tweet from Alx DC us attorney Matthew
Graves is making clear the doj is now
going to Target Americans who were
around the capital on January 6 but did
not enter the building as we enter this
2024 understand that uh it's only just
begun and I've made this I I I I made
this warning uh before after this I said
they're going to go after journalists
which they're doing yep and uh uh
without calling out any of these
individuals we uh I've talked to some
journalists we all know Steve Baker
Blaze contributor is is being targeted
and I've told these these guys hey look
man they're like I have I have a
congressional uh uh press pass I have a
press pass and I'm like you think that
matters with what weing you think that
matters look the Democrats will cheer
for it and they'll make up some argument
as to why you as a journalist should get
locked up the Ken Stein will will play
defense where they the people like the
Cen steens will come out and say I don't
know if journalists should be getting
arrested but I really do think the court
should decide and when they do that's
the right choice then a heavily biased
jury will hear that a conservative
journalist was in the capital and they
will say you should go to prison I want
to play this clip for you so you can
hear exactly what the uh DC's attorney
had to say it's only 30 seconds long
inside into building an important note
when it comes to our prosecutions about
those who remained outside the
building we have used our prosecutorial
discretion to primarily focus on those
who enter the building or those who
engage violent or corrupt conduct on
Capital grounds but if a person knly
entered the restricted area without
authorization they had already committed
a federal crime make no mistake
thousands of people occupied an area
that they were not authorized to be
president in in the first place let's
let's let's break down what he said
people who knowingly then he says
thousands of people as if to imply all
of them what's coming next I think is
going to shock the psyche of the
American people when we go from what are
we at a thousand or so prosecutions or
convictions 89 some OD years Joe Biden
was bragging about it's going to be wild
when they've been setting up these
Capital police officers across the
country we know they did it in Florida
and California it's going to be wild
when you could have been someone who was
just just standing there in the grass
yeah Owen Shroyer didn't go in the
building he went to prison the precedent
is already there you did not have to go
in the building to get arrested Owen
Shroyer now thousands of people are at
risk hey here's an easy way to remove
thousands of trump voters arrest them so
they can't vote don't be surprised if
come August we start seeing Mass raids
overnight pop just people getting locked
up we won't even know these people are
take a look at the censorship waves of
Twitter we all know about the
high-profile censorship but the big play
when Twitter was censoring people was
they were targeting small accounts that
no one knew about or could defend a
trump supporter with 300 followers gets
banned who's he going to tell and who's
going to report it the same thing will
start happening but I believe the next
play is going to be to go after people
who posted on social media before
January 6th in support of January 6th
there are high-profile individuals
tweeting out support for violence now we
know that you can be Ray EPs and
Advocate people crash into the building
y several times and guide people there
and you will get recommendation I think
what six months and if you're Enrique
Toro who wasn't even in DC 20 years what
do you think's going to happen to the
people who are on social media in the
weeks leading up to January 6 who are
saying that people should engage in
these activities I want to clarify I'm
not talking about a guy who went on
social media and said I think people
should protest protest and no no no they
may come after that kind of stuff I'm
talking about there were high-profile
commentators who are saying that people
should engage in more let's just call it
direct actions including
physical protest on the grounds up to
the point like of entering the building
let's not be naive up until January 6 a
lot of people were calling for a big
protest I mean I'm saying but the left
was calling was
calling the left too I don't I I'm not
worried about the people who are being
like we got a protest in DC I'm saying
there were high-profile people with
hundreds of thousands of followers
saying things like storm the building
they will come after those people we've
already seen some people flee the
country
some you know about some you've never
heard of but people who were there funny
funny they're gone I mean they post on
social media I'm not going to say their
names but I would not be surprised to
find that this there's one guy a couple
hundred thousand subscribers one day we
hear the feds rated him I was never in
DC I was never there and they're like
here's multiple videos of you telling
people to engage in criminal activity
you're under arrest well that's who
they'd want to get more than somebody
that was there they want somebody that
has more influence so I wouldn't be
surprised yeah no I wouldn't be
surprised but what they did was entament
they knew there was FBI agents there I
mean whether they tell us that they're
there or not so uh this we talked about
Jeffrey obene earlier about the Honeypot
this was the biggest Honeypot of our
entire uh generation I believe because a
lot of people knew what was going on
that day like the FBI they knew that
there were going to be people there we
talked about this earlier the mag locks
people wouldn't have got in the building
if somebody didn't press a button to let
them in so there's a video of people
there were already people inside they
climbed through windows but there was a
big crowd at a door that was mag locked
magnetically locked there's a video
where people walk up to it like three or
four people they turn around and look up
and point to the door someone hits the
release it could be a protester who
broke in a rioter it could be a security
who knows but I will say even CNN has
reported on more than one occasion
evidence that police fanned people in
two stories one you've got CNN reporting
Joe Scarborough's outrage over the fact
that police let people in the building
and open the doors CN reports Joe
Scarboro says you effing opened the
doors for them to the capital police CNN
also reported on a man who was acquitted
because the judge agreed the police
waved him into the building now I just
like to point out real quick to the CNN
guys who are trying to rag on uh V Gras
Swami the definition of inside job you
know the definition of inside job is
it's actually really really really light
let me uh just pull it up for you a
crime committed by or with the
assistance of a person living or working
on the premises where it
occurred so if uh the police effing open
the door as CNN reported Joe Scarboro
complained about I would call that an
inside job wouldn't you of course I mean
I think it's pretty obvious that
obviously the government knew that they
were going to come in and when you talk
about people getting prosecuted for just
being around I mean Tim they created uh
a lot of people would have just got
misim trespassing but they created if
you I think what is it uh you
interrupted a federal meeting now
they're all charged with felonies now so
I mean the idea that they're going to go
after people that just were bystand you
know just bystanders outside no they're
going to go after everybody I mean I
just don't like he said I think it was a
resource issue not that they have more
resources they're going to continue to
go after more people your tax dollars at
work under Biden crazy you know we saw
this happen with Brandon straa and it
was interesting the uh quote unquote
double standard there between how he was
treated and how Rays has been treated
because we saw Ray UPS clearly on tape
whispering in a person's ear before they
break in the front line storming the
barricades yeah telling people we need
to storm it we need like we need to go
inside we got to go
inside everyone's yelling fed at him
they're call him a fed and um it's it's
funny because the way the media was
responding to this very obviously
strange Silence from the uh agencies on
what he had done the media's response is
well he didn't go in the building he
didn't go in the building come on you
what kind of conspiracy theories do you
guys believing he didn't go inside okay
Brandon straa didn't either and they
were threatening him with like 20 years
and he had to down they were members of
The Proud boys that went away who had
not gone in the building I mean this
isaria wasn't even in DC yeah it doesn't
matter what I think the worst part of
this is it's going to be regular
Americans who were there to see Trump
speak who wandered over who were not
specifically involved in anything who
are now going to live in fear they're
going to question whether they should uh
display Trump flags at their house
they're going to question what they
should say online they're going to qu
they're going to live in paranoia
because they don't know and they're
there's already people who fled the
country I mean I think I there are
regular Americans I know who were on
lawn n DC coincidentally they were there
to see Trump speak who are saying like I
don't know if I should travel
internationally I'm afraid to go to the
airport it really is going to mess with
the psychology of the base of trump some
of them will dig their heels in and say
I don't care come get me but for a lot
of people they'll be afraid of what
they're risking by being open about what
they believe in my favorite thing that
I've seen so far there are a lot of
high-profile individuals as I've
mentioned who are cheering on before
January 6 happened and it may be because
they love to just be these boisterous
characters on the internet were saying
things like yeah we're going to go to
the capital blah blah blah and then to
see these people so quickly after
January 6 no Trump's bad I I'm opposed
to Trump now I don't think anyone should
vote for him I'm for someone else I'm
like oh are you or are you hoping and
praying that they'll Overlook you
because you've bent the knee to the Deep
State yeah I think that's that's the
real question anything to freak uh Trump
V voters out and also to panic Democrats
right like every time they put out a
thing saying we've arrested thousand of
people like the day before the
anniversary of January 6 they said we've
we've there's been over a thousand
arrests made in connection to January 6
and that's both has it has two effects
it angers people who feel like that is
Ultimate million tra day and it makes
Democrats think they're all around me
it's my neighbors if they've already
arrested a th000 people how many people
got away and it's to scare them into
voting for whoever their candidate is
even if they don't like Biden at least
he is not a a republican because all
Republicans are bad that's the narrative
that they want out there and that's
that's very that is very divisive I mean
this is what really bothers me about the
Biden campaign right now which is
ultimately they are leveraging fear
above anything else but claiming that
that's Trump that Trump is the one
saying oh you should be afraid or we're
going to do whatever they they misquote
him with his like I'll be a dictator for
one day all the time to make you feel as
though you being the average you know
Democrat Maybe moderate voter uh think
that if you don't act now the world is
about to fall apart when that's just
fundamentally not true it's a lie that
the left is selling yeah definitely
they've been sing the idea that even
from the beginning I saying oh what did
they think taking over the capital
really do anything to affect the US
government are they crazy like it turn
out yes because it gives us a reason to
prosecute people who don't agree with us
and in fact a way to hold up Trump's
strongest supporters as the Enemy of the
State well before we sarch topics I just
want to say this tomorrow uh Ray eps's
court date is tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. so
I'm going to be outside the courthouse
see what happens so we'll see and if I
get a chance to yell at him I'm going to
call him a Fed no that's allegedly I
don't want to get in trouble one thing
I'm actually curious about here too with
some of these people especially what we
call the magat tourists are the
application of statute of limitations so
I understanding I think what trespassing
is like like two or three years for for
statute of limitations so some of this
stuff I don't think they would be able
to go after well that's why they had the
felony no I'm telling you so that they
can go after but they can't go after
them as it is and they're look you
they've already got people on trespass
in and I made this point in
2021 that if it's a Simpsons joke Homer
is talking to who's he talking to and
he's like you mean if I can invite
someone I'm legally allowed that's right
and then he's like hey Flanders come
over here he's like it doesn't work if
you invite him in it does not work if
you invite them in you can't invite
someone somewhere and then arrest them
for it and this is what we see happening
the police opened the doors and were
Fanning people in the argument from the
left is no no no they were Fanning the
cops to come in does not matter there's
no no signs there's no barricades you
can make an argument that the people who
tore the barricades down and removed
them they committed the crimes agreed
the people who walked and afterwards
seeing cops waving people in they
thought they were being let in so the
first thing that has to happen is Sir
you need to leave your trespassing sorry
about that I'll leave then if they
refuse now you say okay you've been
warned now you're trespassing under
arrest so they shouldn't even have they
shouldn't have even been able to go
after these people in the first place
yeah make they make up reasons and we'
all agree that if they just charge these
people with mis Meers and gave them all
nobody would even be mad but the fact
that they're throwing the book at the
magga granny people that have cancer I
mean you can tell that I mean it's
malicious what they're trying to do
let's let's uh well the granny was from
a different state everyone keeps posting
that picture of the old lady yeah I know
that was a different one but I'm talking
about the one that had cancer that she
was I think she was like 67 thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time